welcome to dc thursday i'm pete
soderling the founder of data council
and the data community fund and welcome
back to our program where we interview
a leader of a top open source data
project or company
we've been running this program now for
the last six months or so and
we've seen lots of great um sharing and
attendance from the community so
we're really happy that you're able to
join us today
we're excited to have a really awesome
guest and chat on active learning
so i'm pleased to welcome dr jennifer
prenke
who's the founder of a new startup
called electio
jennifer has a distinguished past and
history
she was previously the vp of machine
learning at figure eight
and before that she was the chief data
scientist at atlassian
in addition prior to that she was the
principal data scientist at walmart's
lab so she's had lots of great
experience but before that she was a
postdoc researcher at duke university in
the field of neutrino physics
and she also received received her phd
from cerban
in paris in particle physics so jennifer
that is quite a list of achievements
um i wanted to welcome you to the show
thank you pete it's a pleasure to be
to be there with you today so yeah i
mean you're right it's a long road i
think
it's been an interesting journey for me
over the last few years
well i have to say that you're one of
the first people that i ever heard
um pitch machine learning and or
i'm sorry active learning and uh i know
it's been a big passion of yours
um for the past bunch of years can you
tell us
like how did your research lead you into
this field what's the origin story of
active learning for jennifer okay so i
mean
it's it's actually like a there is like
a a long and a short story so maybe i'll
try to recover a little bit like the the
heart oranges right i mean so
as you stated earlier i used to be in
particle physics and so
back in the days when i was doing my phd
so basically like around like a
2000 like i did my phd between 2006
2009 right back in those days uh
particle physics was a space where we
would generate tons of data
and in fact the volumes are very similar
to what you see in the industry today
but you have to remember that these were
the days of like uh
uh you know like a pre-cloud
technologies i mean aws i believe like i
was
created in 2006 but it wasn't
necessarily something very popular
specifically in academia
and uh people like me were basically
looking for solutions to reduce
the amount of data that they would train
their models on right and so
this is a time in my life where i really
nourish the belief that
big data is great you need a lot of data
if you want to find interesting insights
but those insights might be localized in
some specific pieces of your data set
right and so
i wasn't using active learning back in
the days but i really had that
impression that
you can do great things with just a
subset of the data
then fast forward like i eventually the
way i
landed in the industry was that uh i
mean i was very passionate about physics
in fact that was my dream to become a
physicist which i accomplished with my
phd
but unfortunately that was the beginning
of the of the recession right i mean so
there wasn't
there wasn't a lot of money to do
fundamental research
and then this is when i realized that i
could actually use my skills
as an analyst as somebody who's like
very used to work with large data sets
uh in machine learning right so i jumped
into the industry which wasn't uncommon
back in the days for somebody with my
profile
and the very first time when i started
to realize
i'm gonna have to be data smart or i try
to like go back to my
original belief that you might not need
as much data as you think
was when i was at walmart actually so
the story at walmart was
um uh we actually saw i was uh
i was working at walmart when the
acquisition of jet.com happened and so
there was like an internal reorg and
like a
uh like the the funds started to be like
distributed differently and so
my team and my department suddenly like
i had a much lower budget
for data labeling right and so at the
same time the new ceo who was the
founder of jet.com and i
had become the the ceo of walmart uh
also like uh i had this this desire to
increase the number of items to be sold
uh
on the under the e-com like a side of
hallmark right
and so very suddenly i was put in a
weird situation where
we had like maybe like a half a third of
the budget we originally had
for data labeling with uh somewhere
around like a you know like a
10 20 times more items which means 10 to
20 times more data right
and so i i started doing research back
in those days like how am i going to
make this work
and so this is where i first like become
acquainted with machine learning right
and so
uh interestingly like a lot of people
who get started with active learning
normally tend to
start in academia right and so there is
actually a lot of research in academia
i started active learning in an
industrial setting where
this was really meant to help with a
specific problem associated to a
return on investment of the project and
basically making the numbers work
well that's fascinating um and i guess
that was one of the things that drew me
to the concept of active learning as
well
is that it sort of turns the
conventional
wisdom surrounding training data on its
head where we've always thought for
years or maybe we've been sort of
taught or um it's the the message has
been reinforced that the big tech
companies have
this massive unfair advantage because
they have the largest training debt
training training sets but active
learning fundamentally turns that notion
on its head doesn't it yeah absolutely
not so so so i mean that they're like uh
so to go a little bit deeper into like
how active learning works right
so very simply put like active learning
is basically an
answer to this you know like need that
many people
have had that basically they cannot
afford to annotate or label their entire
data set right i mean so
that might be either because uh labeling
is too expensive
it might be because labeling is too slow
or in some areas for example in
healthcare or in legal tech
uh the people doing the annotation needs
to be an expert right i mean so in fact
oil companies tend to use like
geophysicists to try to
uh kind of like uh make a guesstimation
of whether there's gonna be oil in a
specific area based on a certain
certain observations they're gonna make
right and uh you might not have such
experts available in some cases you want
a surgeon to do the annotation and so
basically like you have to pay your
surgeon
it's typical salary to get this data
annotated which can be
crazy expensive right and so uh and so
essentially like the
active learning actually like a i
usually like to say like it's
easy like it's an easy to understand
concept but it's an incredibly hard
concept or process to put into
application right
so for those who are not familiar with
active learning like actually like the
way like
what active learning is trying to do so
basically like first and foremost
it's what you call a semi-supervised uh
training process or paradigm okay so
basically the idea like semi-supervised
by definition is
you work with some liberal data and some
unlabeled data right
uh now where this is interesting is like
as you stated like basically you try to
like sort of reduce like the the amount
of data you're gonna work with
the the use i would still say a large
company or a large data set
is an advantage because the larger the
data set the larger you have to pick
from
and the bigger you can get right because
the useful data is going to be in this
data set right
now uh the uh the advantage of active
learning like was originally so i mean
the way it works is
it's actually a succession of steps that
help you
explore the data and assess its
usability as you keep going right i mean
okay
a lot of people tend to like mix with uh
online learning or other concepts so
basically like active learning is
actually
the definition is pretty simple it's
like the succession of like a selection
step
which is about like selecting a subset
of the data
so how you select is the big question of
course okay
then you annotate this data just the
same way you would do for a regular
uh labeling process right except it's
just a part of the data
you train your model so you're gonna
have like a
model except that this model is gonna be
trained on a small fraction of this data
and then this is like the the trick of
active running is that
you run uh predictions and inference
with this model you just got on the
unlabeled part of the data so you sort
of like generate synthetic labels
and based on what's happening during the
inference step
you go back to the next so basically you
call that a loop you go back to the next
selection step and you say like
now i believe based on what i'm
observing at this point
that these are the records i should be
adding right i mean so it's a selection
of like
select label train for and so forth and
so nice but you're doing this on a
subset on a subset of
of the training data each time so you
keep you keep adding more and more so
it's an
incremental discovery of usefulness of
the data
based on what you observe right i mean
so this of course is reminiscent of you
know like the reason why it's called
active learning it's like
it's the same like active learning way
of teaching to children right which is
observing the reaction to a child or how
good
a child is specifically doing and going
back in the process right
now the trick here is that because your
data the data you're picking from
is not annotated just yet you cannot do
that by just saying okay my model is
failing
at understanding cats right or i
understanding pedestrians because you
don't know what the pedestrians are
besides uh you might have a situation
where the model
fails to understand cats but like the
problem is not necessary you need more
cats you might need more anti-cats or
the other type of objects that cause the
model to believe you know like
this is a cat when it's not right i mean
so a lot of people believe that active
learning is just simply trying to like
uh assess the weaknesses of the model
based on the test step
uh which is not the case in in here
because like uh in the case where you
identify this on the test set you have
an updated data that you may
you can make a decision off right so
here what you need to do because
you are running this inference on the
unannotated data set
you can say this is a bad prediction
because you don't know right yeah
you don't have the labels right what you
can do is basically try to guess
whether you could almost see this as
being like trying to put like a sort of
like a lie detector system around the
model and try to see whether the model
is is seriously believing something or
if the model just makes something up
right
so usually what i like to say is like
models
models cannot tell you they don't know
right i mean they so essentially like
they make a prediction no matter what
what we have to do is basically identify
whether they're
certain or not right i mean so and for
that reason like one of the main ways of
doing active reading that everybody
considers to be the vanilla use case is
basically to look at the
uncertainty of the production through
something like the confidence level
right i mean so in this case
the selection step is done by saying
that uh
i'm just gonna focus on the data that
was predicted with the the lowest
confidence because this is what the
model is going to find the most
interesting right and so okay this is
where problems
begin right i mean so the process on its
own is actually very simple very easy to
understand why you would do this because
this is the way we even
teach children right yeah the the way
you select
is actually pretty complicated so that
so that's the trick
so the trick is is how you do the
selection so so
before we get into that i want to go
back a step um
to your walmart lab story so so did you
implement this in walmart labs and was
it successful
it wasn't earlier that's what's the end
of the story no no so
that was a very early version which was
like so i mean that's it's a little bit
different from the way we do this now
but yes we were pretty successful like
smartly like uh
trying to uh you know like prioritize
some of the most interesting uh
records so yeah and this was around what
what year 2015 or so
i think it was 2015 uh 2016 and 2017.
okay got it and were there other
companies that you were aware of that
were using
so learning in production at the time it
was interesting back then because i
started like this is the point where i
started feeling like somebody has to
make this a carbon
product or a cover like no this is a and
back then i wasn't thinking about
studying my own company right
but i started talking to people it's
like do you also have problems with data
labeling now
you have to put things into context that
back then like walmart like
is you know like the largest
organization right i mean obviously they
have a ton of data which is
typically larger than most companies i
did talk
uh back then with a few people at uh ike
lift and uber or like uh
in the few following years like 2017
2018 etc
people were barely starting to use this
and so i think like
just like myself like we all found out
exactly what i said that
it's a very elegant promising solution
but there is a ton more research that
needs to
actually like make this work in real
life uh
in fact i will go one step further like
research is one piece
but uh the operational side of active
learning is actually pretty complicated
because we're already struggling like to
uh to operationalize like regular
supervised learning processes
production you can imagine how
complicated it can become when you do
something like this
right well you're obviously very
passionate about this space and ever
since i've i've known you you have been
um so this was part of the impetus that
inspired you to start electio so you
decided to start a
whole company around the challenges
surrounding active learning
um so tell me what what does electio do
then
no okay so so basically so just to
finish the story right i mean so
basically when i was at walmart as i
said it's like it was really starting to
dawn on me that you know like
companies are gonna have to use this
we're probably first or early because
because of the huge volume of data that
walmart had right but like
it was very clear to me that the market
would go in this direction right
and it wasn't my ambition to start a
company so i mean
back in those days as you know i started
like evangelizing like the concept of
active reading through
uh blog posts like conferences and so
forth and so on
my my job after walmart so i went to
atlassian
i basically got the incredible
opportunity to start the entire like
machine learning function from scratch
over there
uh and that wasn't necessarily my first
priority because we were starting to
like
build data pipelines don't do the basics
you need to to get started with machine
learning right
uh but it was on the back of my mind
constantly so
i would almost say like you know like
eventually it's like the call to do
something about this became really
strong
and that's when like i completely like
uh opportunistically like a figure eight
right i mean so
another company that used to be known as
crowdflower
or vp of machine learning so it's like
ha ha maybe
that's what we should do right now
what's one of the reasons why i believe
like active learning is still today like
not necessarily very popular is like
normally you would expect that concept
to be like a
broadcasted and publicized by labeling
companies right
the problem is obviously the economics
because the labeling company makes money
based on the volume of data
that their customers are going to
annotate right there is a conflict of
interest in other terms right
this is like i i as much as i felt very
passionate about this sata
uh i'd figure it like there wasn't
really like a a clear opportunity a
clear path for
for the team to like build a product
direction right
and so so eventually as like uh i mean i
think we're really reaching the point
where i mean
i i don't know if you heard this you
probably heard it from me at some point
but even if every single person
on the planet stopped everything they
are doing to annotate data
uh there wouldn't be enough people to
annotate all of the data that we
generate
right and even even i believe even for
use case psycautonomous driving because
there's just so so much data right i
mean so
if you keep in mind that uh you know
like things are gonna
are gonna keep going getting worse we're
gonna have like a like a
time falls more data coming from the
same companies in the future
something is done about that right but
you but you found that the labeling
companies were not as
excited about this approach because they
weren't willing to change their
business model is that essentially what
it boiled down to
that's like like yeah i mean that's the
short answer to this right
now what is interesting as well it's
basically like um
uh so a lot of like i mean thankfully
right
there is also another like i think
people starting to realize that
they can't even service their customers
right i mean so i think like there is a
little bit of pushback from the market
because
even if you want to keep like your your
money stream coming in right i mean
at some point if it like i think
labeling companies see that sometimes
they have like a
time force like more data that they can
even afford to annotate
a lot of customers of labeling companies
complain about the lag right i mean so
a lot
so basically like uh labeling companies
today are starting to realize that
uh you can use machine learning to make
things better and
the typical machine learning act like
australian labeling company would have a
tendency to build
tools to scale up the process of data
labeling right i mean and basically like
uh
you have more and more companies like
living under the principle that
you should do human in the loop data
labeling which essentially means like
you build a process to separate the easy
use cases
or the the easy records you route that
to an automated labeling process
you let the humans take care of the
corner cases right i mean using the
pareto rule where you know like
there's like 20 percent of the data
that's maybe difficult to annotate
you can do it in another way where you
annotate everything with the
machine and you let humans just like
review it quickly right i mean
it's not the best idea in the world
because of course you started humans
to revise everything but it's it's
better than nothing right
uh and there is there is a huge effort
on the market in this direction right
and so in fact like this is also
something that
uh we prone because in order to be
successful with active learning you need
to be able to trust your labels
right this is a pretty important point
where i see like an ad election like i
really saw like the right way of solving
the
the problem not as increasing or
scaling up the amount of data to be
labeled or the labeling process
but scaling down the quantity of data
to be used in a model why because if you
reduce the amount of data
you do solve the data labeling problem
or like the big data labeling problem
the
the even the crisis i would say right
you're also solving all the problems
such as
um first explainability of the data
which part of your data is useful
why is it useful you can actually we do
use active learning also to sort of
diagnose problems you can see in your
model
and generally speaking you also have a
hope of reducing uh
a compute right i mean the amount of
trees
so that's sort of tricky because active
learning in nature causes you to retrain
on a regular basis right
so uh if you do it without like
the dumb way right i mean if you want to
put it that way uh you would have to
like first with like let's say a
subset of the data like let's say ten
percent of your data you select the
additional ten percent you're gonna
retrain on this twenty percent right i
mean so the original uh ten percent you
had plus the ten percent you got so
if you do the math like you're gonna
trade on ten percent twenty percent
thirty percent thirty percent
right you're already over like you're
you're reaching the same amount of
compute right knowing that uh for for
deep learning for instance
uh the relationship is linear between
the amount of data and the amount of
compute right
so uh so that's a problem right i mean
so that's that's also another thing
we're trying to
identify and uh develop ways to do
active learning
in a like way we call that compute
saving active learning
got it and she said on the same batches
got it so so they're definitely some
challenges with active learning
that we can that we can discuss but but
basically at a high level what you're
saying is that as an industry
um we're awash in data we've been taught
that more data is always better
but it turns out that there's
significant bottlenecks that
pop up because of the fact that we're
that we're trying to use all this data
and one of the most obvious bottlenecks
is
we just can't label it all so this whole
notion of
iteration over a machine learning
workflow
you know you don't just build the model
once you have to build it and tweak it
you have to
build it and train it and tweak it you
have to build it and retrain it and
and retweak it so there's this whole
iteration
process that um seems to be
like stagnating because we don't have
modern software development
capacity um and we don't have this
iterative notion
of you know sort of like unblocking
ourselves and some of the things that
matter and so
because of the way specifically active
learning um
handles this approach and really handles
the need for
it sort of enables the need for less
training data it starts to remove a lot
of these blocking issues
in the machine learning workflow is that
right absolutely
so since you're talking about life cycle
i'm gonna add something more as well
which i think is actually pretty
important about active learning and this
this to me is like a
really like once you understand this you
understand like really where active
learning can impact the industry in
general
that's the story yeah i i think it's
also like sort of relevant like my own
story right but like so
when i took my first machine learning
job right i mean shortly after i
finished my
uh my my postdoc right uh i
joined the company where like similar to
what you see today like
uh the the head of engineering is like
we need to do something with ai
machine learning and they didn't know
what right that's what this this stuff
happens today right and so i joined i
was like okay what kind of data do you
guys have right and so oh wait we don't
have much we don't like
you have to figure it out right and it's
just like and a lot of people starting
their careers now in machine learning
would like relate to that to that
sensation
right so anyways so uh so what i did is
like
i didn't have a lot of experience
setting up the data collection process
so i
i started looking into the code what
sort of like that was an advertisement
company so basically like
what sort of like clique who raid am i
going to capture
where how etc i work with the
engineering team
and then i had to sit there for like
three months
right i've been doing something else i
started helping on like the engineering
side a little bit but
it took time to build a historical
training data set
right and so once you had this data and
i i was ecstatic i was like okay
great now i can start building a model i
started doing some work on it
and then to my despair is like oh i
forgot
to collect this thing i should have
collected that this wasn't done the
right way
we you know like basically like we
didn't collect like with sufficiently
enough precision like a specific number
and i started seeing lots of problems in
the data right
at this point it was too late right
there was no going back and like
i'm gonna change my data collection
process and start over right
so you had back in those days to
make your model work for the data right
so it's like you had no other choice
right and it was like something was
missing you had to like find a proxy
like uh you know like a
give up like certain dimensions et
cetera
and and and we were all trained with
that
impression that the flow is you collect
data you build the model you deploy this
model and then you start over that's
what the light cycle is right
uh nowadays so basically like when you
think about this
as we kept being better and big data
started becoming faster
uh higher volume and so forth and so on
that problem started to disappear right
which means that instead of having to
wait for three months to get a training
data set
you might have to just wait a couple of
days or a couple of weeks right
depending on the process obviously
and uh which means that nowadays
you have the option of being picky and
realize you make mistakes and redesign
a more perfect and a more suitable data
set which means that
you can now also tweak the data set to
the model
and this to me this is part partially
what
and so we need to jump back into like
our beliefs that
it doesn't need to be this way you don't
necessarily have to collect data first
freeze this data set and make the model
work for it if you realize
you cannot make the model work if you
realize that the model would get x
like better if you added something
additional
you can go back you can add more data
you can tweak your data collection
process you can add more features
right so it works so it works both ways
and
it sounds like what active learning
allows you to do if i'm not mistaken
is it allows you to understand the
subset
of your training data that's actually
impacting your model
because one of the dirty little secrets
is that all of your training data does
not impact your model
equally is that right that's exactly
right and so this is something that
people don't see just
yet because active learning as i was
explaining before was originally built
for people who have
too much data not enough labeling
capabilities they just want to find the
subset
now you have a tremendous advantage with
this that you can essentially use
and build a feedback loop around this to
say like wait a second let me try to
understand
why this data was impactful to my
training process right
in fact you can also and so these are
the sort of things that we we do a lot
at electro is basically to say that
sometimes you will observe that
the model prefer prefers whatever that
means like a specific subset of the data
it's going to pick that data first and
then eventually when it runs
out of that type of data right i mean so
type of data might be like a
pictures with small pedestrians or small
objects or large objects
or you know like a specific density or a
specific combination of objects or
whatever right
uh when you run out of this the model
suddenly like slows down its learning
rate right i mean you're gonna see that
it seems clear to me that you need more
data of the same type right i mean so
you can actually use
uh the basically what happened during
the active learning process
as a process to refine your data
collection process
find the additional data that's
necessary in fact we started doing that
as well with synthetic data generation
so basically what you do is like you
generate a lot and so in this case in
the case of synthetic data
there is no labeling right because the
data comes like you already have full
understanding of which data you want
generated right i mean so i'm not even
thinking about reducing the
the amount of labeling you're gonna have
to do right what we do is just like try
to get
an understanding of what made the model
comfortable at which point
to basically sort of analyze like this
is the the data you need to generate
more of
and people are completely like i think
uh the vast majority of people who are
even aware of actually
you see active running as a it's made by
a valuable position
in the reduction of data labeling cost
which is
a very small fraction of what you get
so so we've talked about what active
learning is we've talked about
some of the benefits um just so we have
some comparison contrast
um why do people confuse online learning
with active learning what
what what are we missing there well i
mean i think
you know like i think the answer to that
is pretty simple like
look when i started back in the days
right there was no like machine learning
curriculum
at in universities right and so in fact
like a lot of people who
today have like 10 to 15 years of
experience in uh
in machine learning and data science
would be people who were like previously
like uh
applied scientists etc uh and
so now we have we have are lucky to have
like in most universities there are
machine learning courses there are
courses on
here like on the web and so forth and so
on so uh
i mean it's easier for people to learn
machine learning but we're still early
stage right and so a lot of these
courses are still like
the basics right and and and for me like
when the the big missing piece is like
uh i mean there isn't enough awareness
even in academia of what active learning
truly is right and so
uh in fact in many places i've seen
people actually believe that active
learning
is the concept of having to retrain a
model with additional data right
okay you see a lot of people actually
see active learning as being like a
process where
you strategically keep data which is
what active learning is except that
in this case they be sort of what i said
earlier like to state that
since my model is struggling with cats
i'm going to add more cats
which is technically not active learning
because you already have donated the
data in the first place right i mean so
well i guess maybe it's great i mean so
it's like i mean
i'm glad you're doing this podcast to
try to address this today
well maybe it's a little confusing and
you know this goes back to
something that you and i have discussed
over time um it's
should should active learning be be
capitalized
is it is it you know um capital a
capital l learning or
is it is it just a collection of
technologies
because it doesn't seem like it's one
technology right it seems like it's
sort of refers more to the workflow
process of
several steps paradigm right i mean so
it's like it's it's really
it's not a model i mean something else
i've seen is like in fact when we
started elective we would pitch like
basically you should be using active
learning people would say like
i'm good i already have a model and so
you have to educate them on like
active learning can be used with any
model it's just like a wrapper a process
around your model right
so it's like so so we talked about the
the easy standard way of active learning
which is
select a subset of your data train your
model watch the performance
and then sort of go back and and figure
out
a new set of data or a new subset of
data to select
um you you call that the the normal
method of active learning what's that
what's it what
what's a slightly more advanced version
of that model
yeah no so even before just as a
transition from this actually you're
writing so you ask like white people
like uh you know like are not aware of
activity i'm gonna say like
i see a lot of people too who are aware
of active learning
tried active learning and just gave up
right
and so the reason why and this is
another reason why like
you see like a slow adoption cycle on
the market right now is that
people use what i call like traditional
active learning right i mean so
basically like
i talk to a lot of people who say like
oh yeah i know active learning i've done
it before and so
it's it's pretty much the same thing as
to say i've done deep learning before
but as you know you can do deep learning
you can use cnn the lstms you have to
define the number of layers and so forth
and so on
and so i i often see a similarity where
back in the early days of the journey
people were basically like
they would get excited because they read
papers and then they would apply that to
their data set and then they would say
like
okay it's not working for me i give up i
go back to my
old-fashioned traditional machine
learning models right i mean a random
forest or whatever
and the reason for that was that not
eventually as you know today people
are using deep learning all the time
right uh because they realize
that there is a lot of work that needs
to go into tuning the model
identifying like there is there is
actually a lot of heuristic knowledge
right i mean you have like a
uh you will need to get used to it to
get some like a
like intuition around like what's the
best number of players in the case of
deep learning and so forth and so on
right i mean so it's like
people are still at this stage where
because they don't understand this piece
right i mean they just like they try
it fails because usually it does like
the traditional active reading is kind
of like
you have to be extremely lucky for this
to work the right way
uh without to have it or to having to do
any any sort of tuning right
and and they just give up right so to
answer your question about like what i
mean by traditional right
so i'm gonna go back to my flow with
like select
label annotate train uh and infer
and then you go back right critical
piece here and the question
everybody's gonna ask of course is like
what is the select piece how do i select
what
what do i select right so normally what
you do
with active learning is basically like
it's almost like you're trying to listen
to the model usually i say it's like
measuring the model's vitals right
it's when a machine model burns
something is gonna happen to it right i
mean you're gonna have variations in the
weights and the biases of the model
there's gonna be like something with
like a a specific value for the
activation function
uh you're you're gonna have like some
you know like uh uncertainties you can
measure during the inference process
there are
many ways to doing this right i mean you
have like a
cases where you can like uh sort of like
distort the model a little bit to
measure like
agreement across like an ensemble of
similar models and so forth
right and uh you if you measure those
vitals then basically like you can use
those vitals to make
your selection as smart as possible
right okay
the original way or the easiest way to
do activity is essentially to say you're
gonna pick the x records that were
predicted during the inference step with
the least confidence right
and so this is this is interesting
because like you're really like
there are a couple of problems with that
right i mean so it's like first and
foremost like you have to believe that
confidence is a proxy for
interestingness right
right and that might or might not be the
case right
imagine now the case where you are
um you are training a sentiment analysis
model
on english tweets right and for whatever
reason you have some
foreign language in your data set right
let's say three percent of my tweets are
german because i didn't
properly right uh and uh i mean guess
what's gonna happen if i do inference on
those german tweets right
i'm gonna have a little confidence right
do i want to use these
no right because they're exactly the
opposite of what you're trying
right right so that goes and this is
another important part in the fact that
any training data set is made of useful
useless and harmful data
the traditional learning is focused on
trying to remove the useless data making
the assumption you don't have something
like something called harmful data
overtly harmful
uh-huh do this in this case what you're
gonna do is select those german tweets
first and you're actually
building a worse data set over time as
opposed to building a better one right
this is exactly why you cannot just rely
on one feature just like our meta
feature like uh
in the space of like the the happenings
of the model right
so what and and so basically like
usually the way i see this is like
the traditional active learning is a
rules-based algorithm
you're just gonna pre-determine this
rule as being like i'm gonna pick the
500 additional records with the least
confidence
uh and and you have no reason for that
problem with that like and so you get
like
you can be street smart cheating things
a little bit and so that's another
reason why people don't really
uh necessarily like want to spend time
with activision because
uh you have to try right i mean so
basically like if you don't have a
better framework
you're gonna have to try different
conquering strategies so query strategy
is the technical term for the selection
process right
yeah uh and it takes time right and so
at some point you might realize you know
like a
between having to pay an additional like
uh ten thousand dollars for the italy
bringing or having to spend three months
trying to find the right growing
strategy my choice is made right i mean
and now yeah
so i mean basically what i really
believe needs to be done is to believe
and to accept the fact that
we're still an early stage where we we
need to get better
we are using a role at this point uh
usually most people 95 percent of people
doing actually use the same rule
it's very unlikely to work right and
this step
needs to be machine learning driven
right and it can be machine learning
driven because
you can collect data and information
associated to the
the psychology of the model right
and and um so so where where do you see
active learning at in its adoption curve
um
like as an industry will we be able to
sort of
uh educate and sort of solve some of
these challenges and make active
learning
more approachable like what's what's the
secret to doing that do you think no
doubt on my mind because like
we're reaching the point this is
interesting for us because the potential
is amazing the potential is amazing
right but it's it's amazing that
to me that more people don't sort of
embrace embrace this and at least give
it a try
it's the answer is like it's complicated
but like so when when i started the
company like people were really like
almost you know like in disbelief that
this can be done because we still live
in an age where
the big data industry wants to promote
the necessity of using as much data as
possible right
and and uh so when i started the
election like when i was trying to
picture basically like you can actually
use less data right and so actually we
do
things where we we do something called
meta active learning which is a one-shot
way of like trying to predict the useful
data which is basically like a
building a bottle on top of the active
reading process right
and uh when i would try to promote to
people like this is
what you can use right i mean you could
you could actually train the same model
with just a fraction of the data
in fact you could build a better model
because you can also get rid of the
harmful data
that causes problems to their model like
people are like but my teacher
my boss my friends all say i need more
data
i don't believe you right so nowadays
things are quite different
people still don't quite grasp how this
works or how this can be done properly
right
but they need it right i mean so
oftentimes what we see a lot is like
look i
i have no idea like i'm worried that
this is gonna bias my process
i don't see how i can get a better a
better accuracy with less variance which
is also important to say that basically
you can keep the same variance while
reducing the size of the dataset if you
keep the right records right
uh and basically like uh at this point
it's more like a
i need i need this to work for my
machine learning initiative to function
right i mean so one of the core mission
to us and this is very very dear to my
heart it's basically like i believe we
are in the schema where
um you have a lot of amazing machine
learning companies out there
that just cannot get a return on
investment because the money they invest
mostly goes to uh hardware
compute cloud technologies aws credits
right uh data labeling right and the
money should go to research right i mean
at least the decent part of the money
should go to research right i mean so
i think this is a necessary step for
like uh uh
getting the basically like the the the
market back on track and like ensure
and this is really important to me like
it's almost like necessary to ensure
that we don't fall in the next ai winter
this is like you know like and you see
like i don't know the numbers but
uh as per like recent reports from like
analysts on the machine learning market
90 percent of companies claim that they
tried or they have tried something
out of those only 40 percent say that
they see
difference at all uh in terms of what it
brings to their business
right so it's like for me it's like a
big red flag that
we as an industry need to prove that
of course like i think we reached the
point where everybody knows that we can
do amazing things with machine learning
but if you don't do that cheaply
efficiently enough
uh the industry and and the business
people running those companies are gonna
give up on us
yeah that's fascinating um those those
are those are really great thoughts and
um i can see how removing this this high
place of
you know lots of training data um could
definitely
help you know helps smooth that over um
i'm curious to hear from you like what
are some are there some classic use
cases or industries where
active learning makes sense um i i know
we've talked i think in the past about
visual data and other things but um talk
to me a little bit about
um what you've learned over the past
couple years in terms of
um which industries and use cases it
makes most sense for yeah
no so it's it's like you know like so
first and foremost i will say this right
i mean so active learning is not magic
right i mean so
if you have and you have cases where you
actually don't have enough data right i
mean so basically like when when you run
an active learning process like the
the key graph you want to monitor is
called the learning curve right i mean
so learning curve is basically like this
graph of like um
like a performance of the model which
might be accuracy or something else
right
versus the amount of data and and
typically what you see is like something
that plateaus right
so if you like the goal of active
learning in this case is to prioritize
the most useful data as soon as possible
so that
is as possible right
there are like if you randomly add more
data you're more likely to see something
that's evaluation going to plateau as
well right because you have a
diminishing return on like additional
data at some point right
but gonna look more like a regular
cleaner curve right
you have cases where you clearly see
that the model is data start right
so in this case you use active learning
to basically say okay sorry my friends
like you clearly need to collect more
data right you have cases where
you still have enough data to reach the
point where a significant part of your
training set
is uh redundant or you are are uh
irrelevant right when you think about
like so going back to my my concept of
like useful useless and harmful data
the useless data is typically useless
for two reasons right i mean number one
like the data is irrelevant
right so it's like you're training a
facial recognition algorithm and there
is no
there is no one on picture right and you
have the case where the data is
redundant
or the information the data is written
that it doesn't mean you have twice the
same picture or the same record
it means that the information that's
contained in there is something that's
basic to the model
so uh basically like you have cases
where
you still don't reach that like you
might be in a situation where
all of the data is relevant and you
still don't have sufficiently enough
information to call that information
redundant
with something else right so those cases
like for example
there are areas where they are still
struggling
to get data right i mean and so
basically like i would say like uh
there are like slow data collection
processes you could imagine like areas
like
like if you are a healthcare company
working on like a very specific like
type of cancer
something like this right there and so
you're gonna already struggle with the
dimensionality of the data
that you're working with right they are
not necessarily gonna be particularly
prone to using active learning
at the same time these are typically
areas where annotation
or annotating the data is very expensive
right and so you have to organize
usually what you observe is like usually
it's not useful
until it becomes critical right i mean
because you suddenly
fall in the bucket where any record that
like
think of like a health care for example
annotating a record for patient
might be you have to run new tests with
this the patient you need to do
uh you know like draw some blood from
that patient right which is going to be
expensive and slow right so does it does
it make sense to try
um active learning in those high
dimensionality use cases
yeah you could right i mean so basically
like i mean i would say i almost see
active learning as a way to like
diagnose
the written richness of information
right
uh in your data set right i mean and so
so totally something i would do right
uh now the other so the examples like on
the other end of the spectrum where
active learning is typically very
interesting is basically like
autonomous driving right i mean so
autonomous driving you can imagine that
you have similar situations over and
over again right i mean at some point
very quickly the interesting data is
going to be the corner case where
there is an accident in front of the car
right which doesn't happen on a regular
basis right
uh and uh and so in this case like there
is a lot
of redundancy of information because
overall you have lots of data
yeah of course yeah it's basically like
the problem the problem
though is basically like you have to go
back to and this is one of the problems
we're trying to solve like when i said
like compute saving active learning
right
one of the problems we still have with
like most like active running cases is
like it's really a trade-off between
the time you're gonna spend setting it
up
running an incremental training process
which means like typically
it can be more compute if the
compression is not dramatic enough right
uh and uh labeling right so uh
autonomous driving is tricky as well
because
labeling is fairly cheap or can be
fairly cheap right because
this is not the corner case where you
need like a specialist uh
somebody who's a surgeon or a lawyer to
do the annotation right i mean so
there's been a race to the bottom in
terms of the pricing for data labeling
right and so those companies have to ask
themselves right
uh how much do i care about like a you
know go to market
time right and and money right and so
uh and it's usually not an easy answer
to what to give right i mean so
basically like if you if you're gonna
save like a
fifteen thousand dollars in data
labeling by using activity but you're
gonna
spend an additional ten thousand dollars
for compute
and you're gonna spend a month on it do
you or do you not want to do this right
and so active learning is actually
pretty tricky because it's really hard
to predict ahead of time which sort of
compression
you can hope to get right and so on so
this is something that unfortunately we
don't have an answer to just yet but
we're hoping to get an answer in the
in the next few months right but like
it's all about the economics but i would
say
like as we stated earlier there is a
benefit into like trying to understand
usability usefulness of the data in fact
i would see some cases where you want to
use activity
you might figure out from active
learning weight even though i don't have
a lot of data
my learning curve is flat which means
i'm not collecting the right data
i need to change my sensors i need to
i need to drive in different locations
and so forth
i don't see any harm in like at least
trying active learning for
the purpose of diagnosing the process
right you
don't necessarily want to use this in
production right away
that's fascinating so so what advice
would you give for listeners who
want to get started with active learning
like what's the best most approachable
way to get started sorry
i want everybody to try obviously right
yeah no but like first thing i would say
is like
i want people to realize that there is
no such thing as like active learning
right i mean when somebody says like i
tried active learning it's not working
for me it's like chances are you're not
thinking about the problem hard enough
active learning
not just about least confidence right uh
so you have to be patient you have to
gain an understanding of like the
different like ways you have to do this
we're very lucky that like in
2020 there's never been as many papers
published on active learning so we're
way beyond the vanilla use cases at this
point and so we're not the only people
doing research on this uh
the other thing so since you mentioned
uh open source right i mean so
uh obviously we we are a platform that
typically services like enterprise and
startups to try to help them like uh
save money do things more efficiently
identify their problems in fact people
use
us for a variety of different reasons
but we do have a community version which
basically like uh
like the the difference with the
community version and the rest is like
the community version you still have to
do a little bit of work but we have like
a
pre-established list of querying
strategies we have examples of how this
works on different
use cases so basically like if you you
can start using the platform to discover
that for example
there are some querying strategies which
are more advisable
for an object detection problem than for
something else right i mean so i'm not
gonna tell you what because i want
people to go and check for themselves
right
but i mean so so yeah you know like
we're trying to provide tools for like
basically driving awareness for
for active learning so it's like i
encourage everybody to go try this out
and then reach out to us because uh
you can use the platform at least the
community version of the platform even
without paying
that's great we will uh we'll put a link
uh to the
community platform in the show notes so
that folks can check that out
um so i thanks for um chatting jennifer
i always learn so much
about you from you when whenever we chat
especially on on
the the deeper technical topics um i did
want to just shift gears
before we wrap up and ask you uh more of
a
business building company building
question
um what has it been like to to start
electio
as a single founder um what what are the
biggest challenges that you've faced
um over the last few years because i
know with any startup
i've started several and all of us have
challenges and ups and downs
but i'm curious about what you've
learned about yourself and
and uh and how you might frame any
advice for folks in the community who
might want to start a company
no so i mean what's interesting about my
journey is like i never want like i
almost i call myself the reluctant
entrepreneur like all the accidental
entrepreneur it's like really like
i i never meant for this to happen i
just got really mad at some point that
nobody was working on this and i saw
such a huge opportunity and
such a huge need on the market right i
mean so it's like i mean i would say
like one of the
the strength i had is like i didn't
start a business for the purpose of
starting a business i started a business
for the sake of solving a problem which
i knew from my figure eight days to be a
problem for me sorry uh i mean
talking about the piece about like being
a solo entrepreneur right i mean so
i mean it was i mean same thing was an
accident right
it's like basically like uh i i did not
start the conference saying like i'm
gonna prove to the world that i can
start a company on my own right
it was more like basically like i am on
a mission and i didn't find anybody else
was like really
passionate about this mission at the
same point in time right so
it was it was obviously a challenge for
you like getting uh
getting people to like uh back us up
trust me specifically being like a
category builder right i mean so
basically like uh
even like teaching to investors was
always a challenge that basically like
why
i mean i got that question a lot like if
this is such a
promising technology why is nobody else
doing it just yet i mean my answer is
like somebody has to be the first right
i mean so
maybe that's me in this case right uh
but yeah i mean so um
uh i mean i would say the advantage i
saw as
a solo entrepreneur uh is is basically
like the ability of like align
all the strategies right because one of
the problems like i don't know if you're
you're aware of that but like one of the
big reasons why people tend to fail
early speed with their companies is that
there is a disagreement in the direction
of the company between the farmers
so at least i did not have that problem
to deal with and so i think uh
we've been like pretty efficient like
building on and figuring out product
market fit early stage because
i was able to align marketing with
products with engineering with
you know like make the right strategic
hires at the right time without having
to argue with somebody yes
yeah well starting a company is
definitely challenging and um
sometimes it's easier with someone maybe
maybe you're right sometimes
it could be easier um without that
co-founder to
fight with yeah um
well this this has been a great chat
jennifer um i want to thank you for
again for joining us and
um really appreciate you being here and
sharing all of your wisdom with the
community
so best of luck with electio thank you
uh so i just wanted to make a couple uh
mentions to the community
before we sign off um please don't
forget to leave us some comments on
today's episode there's a
survey in the sidebar that you can check
out we love it when you sound off and
let us know
what you like or don't like about the
show also
i wanted to mention that data council is
doing a
2021 open source data tools community
survey
we have one more week left where you can
submit your responses on your top three
favorite
open source data tools we've gotten
literally hundreds and hundreds of
responses from the community so far so
please make sure to check that out take
20 seconds it's the shortest survey
i have ever seen in my life so please
fill that out and then don't forget to
share it with your friends and your
community
and your co-workers we'd really
appreciate that
and finally next week february 25th
i'll be having a chat on starting a data
company with patrick thompson
from iteratively um so don't forget to
subscribe
hit the bell button so that you get the
notifications and we look forward to
seeing you
next time